[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
SCOTT HUGHES: All right.
So welcome back.
I had a little bit of a break.
Before I get into--
I go over my quick
recap, you hopefully all
have seen the
announcements that we're
going to delay the due date
of the next problem set
until Tuesday.
That's in part because some of
the material that appears on it
is what we're going to talk
about in today's lecture.
So I want to make sure you've
at least seen a lecture on all
the topics before you try to
do some of the problems on it.
In truth, you could probably--
based on things I talked
about in the previous lecture,
you could probably deduce a
lot of what you need to do,
but still, it's good to go
over it a little bit more
methodically.
And I'm trying to think.
Is there anything
else I want to say?
Yeah.
So then the next problem set
will be posted a week from--
is that right?
Yeah, I think we post
a week from today.
So let me just get
back to what you
were talking about last time.
So I began introducing
some geometric concepts
and some quantities that
we use to describe matter.
We've done a lot
of things so far
that's appropriate
for describing
kind of the kinematics
of particles,
but that's rather restrictive.
We want to talk about a broader
class of things than that.
And I began by introducing
something which is, again,
fairly simple, but
it's a useful tool
for beginning to think
about how we are going
to mathematically categorize
certain important types
of matter.
Pardon me while I put
some of my notes away.
Also, pardon me.
I'm recovering from a--
I caught a terrible cold
over the long weekend,
and I'm coughing incessantly.
So I will be occasionally
sucking on a cough drop.
So I introduced the quantity
called the number four-vector.
And that is given by-- imagine
you have sort of a-- it's best
to think about this in the
context of something like dust.
So you have some kind of
non-interacting little
agglomeration of tiny particles.
And in the rest frame of
an element of this dust--
so imagine you go
into-- well, I'm
going to define the rest
frame of that element
by saying imagine you've
got a cubic nanometer of it
or something like that.
And you go into the
frame where everything
in that cubic nanometer
is on average at rest.
We'll call n sub 0
the rest density.
So I forgot to write that down.
So that's the rest density.
The rest-- pardon me--
number density.
So I go into that rest frame.
That tells me how many
little dust particles there
are per cubic volume,
per element of volume.
Multiply that by the
four-vector that--
excuse me-- the four-velocity
describing that element.
And we're going to call
that capital N. So that's
a vector that describes--
its components describe
the number density
in some other
frame of reference,
in any frame of reference.
And the flux, talking about
how those dust particles
flow from one
element to another.
So we spent a little
bit of time talking
about how to define
volume elements
in a covariant fashion.
I'm not going to
go through that,
but part of the
punchline of doing that
is that we're going to
define a sort of what
I call a covariant formulation
of conservation of number.
It's going to be the
spacetime divergence
of that vector is equal to 0.
That holds-- this equation holds
in all frames of reference.
If I choose a particular frame
of reference, in other words,
I define a particular time,
I define a particular set
of spatial
coordinates, I can then
break this up and
say that this is
equivalent to saying that
the time derivative of the t
component of that plus
the spatial divergence,
the spatial confluence
is that they sum to 0.
I can also take this thing
and integrate over a--
oops-- it would help to have
one element defined here.
I integrate this over a
four-dimensional volume.
And by my conservation law,
I must get 0 when I do that.
Again, having chosen a
particular frame, defined what
time means, defined
what space means,
I can then split this
out into a statement
that the time derivative of
the volume integral of the time
component of this
thing is balanced
by the flux of the number
across the boundaries
of a particular three-volume.
I remind you this notation,
this sort of delta V3
means the boundaries
of the V3 that's
used under this integral.
So we talked a little bit
about a few other four-vectors
that are used.
In particular I
introduced some stuff
that we use in
electricity and magnetism.
But I want to switch gears.
In particular, I want
to introduce and discuss
in some detail one of the
most important tensors
we are going to use all term.
So I motivated this by saying
imagine I have a cloud of dust.
And I won't recreate
one, because I
am getting over a cold.
And I don't want to
breathe chalk dust.
So I imagine I make a little
cloud of these things here.
So far we've
characterized this thing
by just counting the
number of dust particles
that are in there.
But that's not all
there is to it, right?
That dust has other properties.
And so the next thing
which I would like to do
is let's consider the energy and
the momentum of every particle
of dust in that cloud.
So let's just
imagine, again, we're
going to start with
something simple,
and then we'll kind
of walk up from there
to a more generic situation.
Let's imagine that
my cloud consists
of particles that
are all identical,
and each dust particle
has the same rest mass.
So suppose this guy
has a rest mass m.
So one of the things
that I might want to do
is in addition to characterizing
this dust by saying
that the number density--
[COUGHING] excuse me--
in addition to saying
that the number
density in a particular
frame is n or n0,
let's go into the rest
frame of this thing.
I might be interested in knowing
about the rest energy density.
So I'm going to denote the rest
energy density by rho sub 0.
Each particle has
a rest energy of m.
Remember, c is equal to 1.
So mc squared, if you want
to hold to the formula
that we've all known and
loved since we were babies.
So that's the rest energy.
And then how many-- if I want
to get the rest energy density,
I count up the number
in each volume,
or the number per unit volume.
So that's m times n0.
So that's the rest energy
density of this thing.
Great.
Let's now ask, OK, so that's
what it looks like in the rest
frame of this dust element.
Let's imagine that I now
bop into a frame that
is moving with some speed
relative to this rest frame.
In this frame, the
energy density--
I'm not going to say rest
energy density, because I'm
no longer in the rest frame.
But the energy
density in this frame,
which I will denote by rho
without the subscript 0
is going to be the
energy of each particle.
So that's gamma times m.
And the volume is
going to be length--
it's going to be a
little bit larger.
Sorry.
The volume is smaller because
of a length contraction.
And so this guy actually gets
boosted up to gamma and 0.
So in this frame,
the energy density
is larger than the rest energy--
excuse me-- the rest energy
density with a gamma squared
factor.
Straightforward algebra.
But I want you to stop and think
about what that's telling us.
If this rho were a
component of a four-vector,
is there any way I could get a
gamma squared out of this thing
by bopping between
reference frames?
No, right?
When I do that, it's linear
in the Lorentz transformation
matrix.
There's no way with a
linear transformation
that I would pick up
two powers of gamma.
This is not how a-- you
guys are probably all
used to from Newtonian physics
of thinking of energy density
as a scalar.
This is not a Lorentz scalar.
A scalar is the same in
all frames of reference.
So this is a different quantity.
So it's neither a four-vector
component nor a scalar.
It's got two of those
things, so it's not
going to surprise you
that what's actually
going on here is we are picking
out-- what we've done here
is we've picked out a particular
component of a tensor.
Let's think a little
bit more methodically
about what tensor that must be.
So when I originally wrote down
my rho 0 here, I sort of just
argued on physical
grounds that it
is the energy of every particle
times the number of particles
per unit volume of that thing.
Well, the energy that I
use in this thing doing it
in both the rest frame and
in the other frame, those
are the time-like components
of a particular four-vector.
So we assembled rho
by combining energy,
which is the time-like
component of the four-momentum
with number density, which
is the time-like component
of the number vector that I
just recapped a few minutes ago.
So those are two time-like
components of four-vectors
here.
So that rho is something like--
well, let's put it this way.
I can write this as
pt nt, which tells me
that it belongs to a tensor.
So let's define this
as some tt of a tensor
that I've not carefully
introduced yet.
There is some underlying
tensor that we
have built by looking at the--
there are various
names for this.
We'll call it the tensor product
of two different four-vectors.
So if I write this in the kind
of abstract tensor notation
that I've used occasionally--
in some of your textbooks this
would be written with
a bold faced capital T,
I will use a double
over line for this.
We might say that this t is the
tensor product of the number
vector with the four-momentum.
Now, the number vector
is itself just n0 times
the four-velocity.
And my momentum, since all
the particles, I'm assuming,
are the same is just the rest
mass times the four-momentum.
This thing actually looks kind
of like the four-velocity times
four-velocity with a
prefactor And that prefactor
is nothing more than
the rest density.
So another way to
say this is that if I
make my cloud of
dust, and I go in
and I look at every
little element in it,
I take the rest energy density
of every element in that dust.
I construct the
tensor that comes
from making the tensor
product of the four-velocity
of that dust with itself.
That is what this geometric
object is equal to.
If you want to write this
in index notation, which
is how we will write
it 99.8% of the time,
we would say that component
alpha beta of this quantity t
is that rest density
times u alpha u beta.
So this is-- in terms
of the physics we're
going to do this
term, this is perhaps
the most important quantity
that we're going to talk about.
So it's worth understanding
what this thing is really
telling us.
So if I wanted to get these
components, the alpha beta,
out of this thing from this
sort of abstract notation
of the tensor, I'll remind
you that we can do this
by taking the tensor and
plugging into its slots
the basis 1 forms, which
tell me something about--
basis 1 forms are
really useful for sort
of measuring fluxes across
in a particular direction.
And in fact, this quantity has
the geometric interpretation--
think of this as the flux
of momentum component alpha
in the beta direction.
So if we look at this
component by component,
it's worth doing that.
So let's do the tt
or 00 component.
So this is the one
we've already done.
This is just rho 0 ut ut.
It's just rho in that thing.
According to the words
I've written down here,
this is the flux of
pt in the t direction.
So pt tells me about energy.
The flux of energy in the
energy direction refers to--
so here's my water flowing
in the time-like direction,
just sitting there apparently
doing nothing, but no,
it's moving through time.
This is energy
flowing through time.
It's energy density, all sort of
locked up in stable equilibrium
here.
But if somebody comes in someday
with a nice cup of anti-water
and combines it, we get to
have all that energy released.
And we can enjoy that
for a few femtoseconds
before we evaporate.
Let's look at the
other components.
So T0i, you can
take the definition
and plug it in in terms
of the components.
It's obviously ut
times ui, but still use
the definition by words.
So this is the flux of p
sub t in the xi direction.
This is talking
about energy moving
in a particular direction.
This is nothing more than
energy flux, energy sort of flux
that we are used to think
about, not flowing through time,
but flowing through space.
Now, T0i, this is the
flux of momentum component
i in the t direction.
So this tells me about
momentum density.
So if I had this
stuff flowing, there's
some momentum associated
with that flow.
You can count up the amount of
mass and every little volume.
Divide by that volume.
Take some ratios.
That is the density of momentum.
And finally, this last one,
flux of p i in the xj direction,
there's really no
great wisdom for that.
This is nothing more
than momentum flux.
If I have a bucket of water
and things are sort of sloshing
around, there's some
momentum moving,
and the whole assembly is
moving in some direction,
we can get a flow of
momentum going in kind
of a non-normal direction.
As long as it goes in
a normal direction,
it might be moving
along its flow.
I'm going to talk about
that in a few moments
when I talk about a few
different kinds of stress
energy tensors.
The key thing which I
want you to be aware of
is that under the
hood of this thing,
we're going to talk about
different kinds of stress
energy tensors for a
little later in this class.
But this basic
interpretation of the way
to think about the
different components,
it holds for all of them.
So this is good
intuition to have.
One thing which
is worth noting is
if you look at--
if you actually--
let's take the form of
the stress energy tensor
that corresponds to the dust.
So I'm going to write out
all four of my components.
I've already given you T00.
T0i, I can write that as
gamma squared rho 0 vi T0i
equals gamma squared rho 0 vi.
This guy is gamma
squared rho 0 vi vj.
There's two elements
of symmetry here,
which I want to emphasize.
Notice energy density
and momentum flux.
Sorry.
Energy flux and momentum
density, those words
are important.
Energy flux and
momentum density,
they're exactly the same.
That is actually
true in all physics.
It's clouded by the fact,
though, that in most units
that we measure things, we don't
typically use speed of light
equal to 1.
So when you look at these kind
of quantities in the physics
that you are more used to,
you would find your energy,
your energy flux,
your momentum density
will have different
units, because you'll
have factors of c that
come into there that
convert from 1 momentum,
and energy, and time flow,
and space flow.
Also, you don't usually include
rest mass and rest energy
in the energy flows
and momentum densities
that you've probably been
familiar with in the past.
So it's when we do
relativity, and we
set the speed of
light equal to 1
that this symmetry between
energy flux and momentum
density becomes apparent.
Question.
AUDIENCE: The second one, do
you mean rho 1 will be there?
SCOTT HUGHES: Sorry.
This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, on
the right-hand side.
SCOTT HUGHES: On
This is--
AUDIENCE: Rho i.
SCOTT HUGHES: No,
this is definitely
what I mean to write down here.
So this is-- what I've
done, I've taken advantage
of the fact that I can write--
let's see.
Do I have it down somewhere?
Yeah.
So what I've done
over here is I have
written the fact-- so u sub t,
ut is just the gamma factor.
And I didn't explicitly
write out what t--
the i components, but you get
a similar factor that way.
So no, that is correct that way.
AUDIENCE: So that's why you
mean the first and the second
are the same.
SCOTT HUGHES: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I just want to emphasize--
I mean, the key thing
which I want to emphasize
is when you do it in the physics
that you guys have generally
all seen up till now,
it won't look that way.
And there's two causes of that.
One is you're not used to
necessarily working in units
where the speed of light is 1.
And two, rest energy is
built into these definitions.
That shifts things a little bit.
The other thing which
I want to emphasize
is notice this is symmetric
under exchange of indices.
Now, it's obvious for dust.
It comes right back to
the fact that these guys--
that those indices
enter like so.
It's an exterior product of
the four-velocity with itself.
I'm not going to go
through in detail,
but there is a
physical motivation
that I will sketch
in a few moments that
argues that it must
be symmetric like this
in all physical cases.
I have a detailed
sketch of this.
I keep using the word sketch,
because my mind wants to say
proof, but it ain't a proof.
It's sort of a motivation.
And so I will post it for
everyone to go through,
but I will sort of illuminate
it in a couple of moments.
Basically, if this is
not true, if it's not
the case this is symmetric,
a physical absurdity
can be set up.
I'll describe that
in a few moments.
So most of the
world is not dust.
So this is a decent example for
helping to understand things.
But we are going
to want to do more
complicated and
interesting examples.
Pardon me.
Just one second.
Let me just check
here with this page.
Yeah.
So for us, the way that
we are going to do this,
there is a fairly
general recipe that one
can imagine applying to this.
I'm going to save it for a
little later in the class.
It sort of borrows some
techniques from field theory.
Basically, if you can write
down a Lagrangian density that
describes the fifth system
that you're under study,
there's a particular
variation you can do,
that stress energy
tensor emerges from.
But for now, the key
thing which I want to say
is that we basically are going
to deduce what the stress
energy tensor looks
like by essentially
going into a particular frame--
we'll call it the rest frame.
It's usually the rest
frame of some element
of the material being studied--
and thinking carefully about
this physical definition
of what the different
components mean.
This is not the most
rigorous way to do it,
but it's a good way to
get started and develop
some intuition.
So let me give one example
that for many of us
in astrophysics, this is
probably the one stress energy
tensor that we write
down and use over,
and over, and over
again in our career.
And it's rare we
do anything more
than this in many, many cases.
This is called a perfect fluid.
So what is perfect
about a perfect fluid?
It begs the question here.
What is perfect
referring to here?
So a perfect fluid
is a fluid in which
there is no energy flow in what
I will call the "rest" frame.
I put rest in
quotes, because you
have to sort of define it
from the context of what
your fluid is here.
Basically, what
it means is I can
find a frame in which
each fluid element there
is no energy flow there.
If a frame exists
where that happens,
there's a candidate
to be a perfect fluid.
And I also require there
to be no lateral stresses.
Lateral stresses
refer to this Tij
when i and j are not
equal to one another.
So this sort of
refers to-- imagine
that I have some-- let's
say going into the board
is the y direction.
So if there's like some
y stress that is somehow
being transported
in the x direction,
that would be a lateral stress.
Physically, this is actually--
that kind of a stress
is hugely important when
one is studying fluids.
And one characterizes
it by a quantity
known as the viscosity.
Viscosity tells me about how
stress gets transported--
how momentum, rather,
gets transported
in a non-normal direction,
against the direction
in which the fluid is moving.
So my perfect fluid
has no viscosity.
And I'll just conclude.
I want to make-- there's a
very important point here.
A fluid that has no
viscosity is a fluid
that doesn't get anything wet.
So this refers to when you
pour water on yourself,
the reason your hand
gets wet is that there's
some viscosity that actually
prevents it-- causes there
to be sort of a shearing
force, which causes the water
to stick to your skin.
So a perfect fluid,
this has been described
as the physics of dry water.
So it is-- anyone who's
in applied math will know.
They'll sort of roll their
eyes and say, OK, fine,
we'll do this sort of infant
version of fluid first.
And then a lot of the
action and a lot of the fun
comes from putting in viscosity
and doing the real fluids.
For the purposes of our class,
what this boils down to is
this tells me that the
physics of this quantity
is totally dominated
by the fluid's energy
density and its pressure.
The pressure is an
isotropic spatial stress.
So in this particular frame,
where I have no energy being
transported, then the
stress energy tensor can be
represented as energy density
as usual up in the-- whoops,
over there now--
up in the tt component.
There is no energy flux.
By symmetry, if
there's no energy flux,
there is no momentum of density.
And my spatial stresses
are totally isotropic,
and none of them are lateral.
So it just looks like this,
the diagonal of rho p, p, p, p.
As I said, this is
actually something
that we're going to use over,
and over, and over again.
This is actually a--
so you can actually
consider my dust
stress energy tensor
to be a perfect fluid
with no pressure.
So this actually
subsumes this other one.
I will-- just
illustrative purposes,
I'll show an example of a
case that cannot be thought
of as a perfect fluid.
But we will tend to use
this a lot in our class.
And as I will demonstrate
in just a moment,
we're going to find
that this ends up
playing an important
role in generating
gravitational fields.
What's interesting
about this is you
guys are probably
used to the idea
that mass generates
gravity, and then
throw in a c square
that tells you energy
to generating gravity.
But it's also-- we're going to
see pressure generates gravity.
And it's connected to the
mathematical structure
of this guy here.
So notice I've written
an equal dot here.
So this is just the
way this is represented
in this particular frame.
I would like to write this in a
more covariant form, something
that does not rely on me
going into a particular frame
of reference.
So the trick which I'm
going to use for this
is when I think about
that form there--
so the rho piece of it, clearly,
what I'm doing there is I'm
picking out--
that is-- can be thought of--
as the energy density multiplied
by the tensor product of
the four-velocity that
describes a particular
element of this fluid.
So I can write, again, using
this sort of abstract notation.
This piece of it
looks like this.
And so if I go into
the frame, if I
go into the rest frame of
the fluid, that's just my u
is 1 and 0.
And the spatial
components, that builds
my upper left-hand
corner of this tensor.
How do I get the rest of this?
Well, to get the rest of
it, these are all sort of
picked out of components
of the tensor that
are orthogonal to u.
And I put an Easter
egg in p set 1.
You guys developed
a tensor that allows
me to build-- it's a
geometric object that
allows me to describe things
that are orthogonal to a given
four-vector.
So if I take the
projection tensor
that you guys built
one piece at 1,
which looks like the
metric plus the extern--
the tensor product of a
four-vector with itself,
that gives me the p's that
go into that component.
Or if I write this
in index notation,
I can do it in two ways.
I will also emphasize
that there are
few moments in this class
where I sort of urge
you to take the sort of
long-term memory synapses
and switch them on.
This is one of those moments.
In a couple of
lectures, we're going
to introduce the principle
of equivalence, which
is the physical
principle by which we're
going to argue how we go
from formulas that work
in special relativity
to formulas
that work in general relativity.
And by invoking the
principle of equivalence,
we're going to see
that when we want
to describe perfect fluids
in a general spacetime,
not just in special relativity
and general relativity,
it's exactly this formula.
I just need to modify
what the metric means,
but that will allow
me to carry that over.
Let me see.
So my notes are a little
bit disorganized here.
There's a piece that I--
every year I want to
clean this bit up,
and every year at
this time of year,
I have 70 gajillion
administrative tasks.
And I end up getting
behind schedule.
So I will clean
this up on the fly.
So there's a couple
of points which
I want to make about this.
Let me do this point first.
So by virtue of taking a
graduate physics class,
I'm confident you guys know
about Newtonian gravity.
One can write the field
equation for Newtonian gravity
as essentially a
differential equation
for the potential that governs
Newtonian gravitational
interaction.
So let's call phi sub g
the Newtonian gravitational
interaction.
Whoops.
And I can write a
field equation that's
governing it as essentially
its Poisson's equation.
So the Laplace operator
acting on that potential
is up to a constant
equal to the--
we usually learn it in
terms of mass density.
We're working in units where the
speed of light is equal to 1.
So it could just as well
be the energy density.
So you've all kind of seen that.
Now, if we think
about how we're going
to carry this forward
and make gravity
a relativistic
interaction, this equation
should right away
make us suspicious,
because we spent several
minutes earlier today
talking about the fact
that this is not a scalar.
This is a component of a tensor.
A physical theory
which tries to pick out
just one component
of a geometric tensor
is not a healthy theory.
It would be like if
you had sort of learned
in E&M that there was
a preferred direction
of the electric field.
If there's a particular set
of Maxwell's equations for Ex,
and a different set of
Maxwell's equations for Ey.
That would just be nonsense.
Nature doesn't pick out spatial
components of any one being
particularly having some
weight over the others,
and the same thing holds in
relativity for spacetime.
So when we make this into
a relativistic theory,
we're going to say if
this component of a tensor
plays a large role in
gravity to make this
into a geometric object that
makes a large role in gravity,
I'm going to have to-- so
let's call this my Newtonian
equation.
My Einsteinian equation--
I'm going to put an
equal sign in quotes
here, because there's a
lot of details to fill in.
But what's going to go on
the right-hand side of this
has to be something that
involves the stress energy
tensor.
Newton picks out one component
stress energy tensor.
Relativity doesn't let me pick
out particular components.
So whatever I get when
I do Einstein's gravity,
the whole stress
energy tensor is
going to be important in setting
the source of my gravity.
That then sort of
says, well, then what
the heck do you do with
this left-hand side?
That is, in fact, going to be
starting probably on Tuesday
the subject of the next couple
of lectures, basically going
all the way up to spring break.
The week before spring break
is when we complete the story
of what goes on the
right-hand side--
excuse me-- the left-hand
side of this equation.
But what I will tell
you is that it is indeed
going to involve two derivatives
of a potential-like object.
And the potential-like
object is actually
going to turn out to be
the metric of spacetime.
So that's kind of where
we're going with this.
Let's do a little bit more
physics with the stress energy
tensor.
So I have somewhat
more detailed notes,
which I will post online, which
I am not going to go through
in great detail here.
But I'm going to
kind of sketch this.
So one is that I
would like to prove--
again, that word is a little
bit of an overstatement,
but at least motivate the
symmetry of this tensor.
I'm just going to focus on
the spatial bits of this.
That'll be enough.
Like I said, you can kind
of see that T0i and ti0 are
the same thing by thinking
about the physical meaning
of four-momentum and what
a flux of four-momentum is.
This one, there's kind of a
cute calculation you can do.
So imagine you have some
little cube of stuff.
It could be immersed in some
field or fluid, something
that is described by a
field of stress energy.
And so to start out with,
let's look at how the flux--
remember what t alpha
beta, or really Tij
tells me about is
the flux of momentum
in a particular direction.
It's telling me about
the amount of momentum
going into this box on one side
and coming out on the other.
So I'm going to look
at the momentum flux
into and out of this box.
And so what I'm going to do
is let's look at the momentum
going into the sides that are--
so let's call this the
top and the bottom here.
What I'm going to do
then is number the four
sides, the other four
sides of the box, not
the top and the bottom--
so let's call this side,
which is sort of facing away
from us here, that side one.
The one that is facing
us that sort of points
out in the x direction,
I'll call that two.
This side here, I
will call three.
And the one that is on
the back I will call four.
Apologies for the little
bit of a busy picture here.
But just what you
want to do is sort
of imagine there's a
cube in front of you,
and you go around and
label the four sides.
What we'd like to
do is calculate
what is the force
that is flowing
through each of these four
sides, 1, 2, 3, and 4.
Just ignore the top and the
bottom for just a second.
I'll describe why that
is in just a moment.
So if I look at the force
on face one, well, face one,
it is--
pardon me-- I
mislabeled my sides.
I want to be synced
up with my notes,
and so I realize it's annoying.
And I'm very sorry about that.
But if I mess this
up, I will get out
of sync with what I
have written down.
So the one that is
facing us is side one.
Two is on the right-hand side.
Three is the back.
Four is on the left-hand side.
My apologies for that.
But I think it's important
we get that right so I don't
get out of sync with myself.
So the total force
on face one is
what I get by basically adding
up all the flux of momentum
flowing through face one.
So force on face one, that is--
the i-th component
of that is what
I get when I integrate
that over face one, which
is normal to the x-axis.
Each side of the
cube is little l.
So it's Tix l squared.
Force on face two,
now this is the one
that is normal for the y-axis.
And so this guy looks
like Tiy l squared.
And you continue this F3--
if you look at, and
you if you assume
that this thing is small,
it's approximately the same
as the force on F1.
It'll become equal in the
limit of the q becoming
infinitesimally small.
And this is approximately the
same as the force on face two.
So that tells us that
there's no unbalanced force
on this thing, which is great.
Basically, it means that there's
no unbalanced force causing
this little element
to accelerate away.
One of the reasons why I am
focusing on these four sides,
though, is I would also
like to consider torques
that are acting on this thing.
And here's where I'm going to
skip over a couple of details
and just leave a
few notes for you
guys to look at, because
we're a little short on time
with other things.
This calculation is
straightforward, but it gets--
I already screwed
up a detail here.
I don't want to sort of risk
messing up a few other things.
What I want to do is
consider the torques
about an axis that sort
of runs through the middle
of this thing that goes from
the top and the bottom of this.
So go through and just
add up all the torques
associated with these
little forces about an axis
in the center of--
that goes through the
center of this cube.
So I'm going to--
like I said, I'm
going to leave out the details,
but basically, you go through,
and you do the usual
r cross f to get
the forces, the torques
associated with each
of these different faces.
And what you'll find
when you do this
is that there is a net
torque that looks like l
cubed times Txy minus Tyx.
Again, though, this scales
with the size of the cube.
So you look at this and
kind of go, well, who cares?
It's a little bit there.
Maybe it spins up a little bit.
But in the limit,
the thing going to 0,
there's no net effect.
Well, let's be a little
bit careful about this.
What is the moment of
inertia of this cube?
I don't know exactly,
but I know that it's
going to be something like
the mass of this cube.
We'll call that l cubed times
its mass density, or its energy
density.
And it's going to involve two
powers of the only length scale
characterizing this thing.
And there will be
some prefactor alpha.
There will be some
number that's related
to the geometry of this.
An integral or two
will easily work out
what the alpha is and
make this more precise.
But the key bit which
I want to emphasize
is that this is
something that scales
as the size of the fifth power.
So yeah, the torque
vanishes as l goes to 0,
but it does so with
the cubed power.
It doesn't vanish as quickly as
the moment of inertia vanishes.
And I'll remind you,
the angular acceleration
of the cube, theta double
dot, is the torque divided
by the moment of inertia.
So this is something that
is proportional to Txy
minus Tyx divided by l squared.
So yeah, the torque does
vanish as l goes to 0,
but the moment of
inertia vanishes
more rapidly as l goes to 0.
That sort of suggests that
if we're in a screw universe,
little microscopic
vortices are just
going to start randomly
oscillating in any cup of water
that you pour in front of you.
Now, I don't have a proof
that nature abhors that,
but it seems pretty screwy.
And so the case that most
textbooks make at this point
is to say, physics
indicates we must
have Txy strictly equal
to Tyx in all cases,
independent of what the
size of this thing is.
That had better just be a
bloody 0 in the numerator
in order to prevent
this physical absurdity
from being set up.
Repeat the exercise
by looking at torques
around the other axes.
And that drives you
to the statement
that this thing
must, in general,
be spatially symmetric.
And again, physics of the way
that energy and momentum behave
in relativity makes our sort of
timespace component symmetric
as well.
I emphasize this is not a proof.
This is really just a
physical motivation.
This is the kind of thing that
I'm a bloody astrophysicist.
I like this kind of stuff.
There is a different way of
developing the stress energy
tensor, as I said, that comes
from a variational principle
sort of based on
sort of quantum field
theoretic type of methods.
And the symmetry in
that case is manifest.
It really does sort of come up.
But this is a good way of just
motivating the fact that you're
not going to have
any non-diagonal--
or excuse-- non-symmetric
stress energy tensors.
If you did, you would have
really bizarre matter.
Now, the stress
energy tensor has
this physical interpretation
that it tells me
about the flow of energy and the
flow of momentum in spacetime.
As such, it is the
tool by which we
are going to put conservation
of energy and conservation
of momentum into our theory.
And the way we're
going to do this
is with a remarkably
simple equation.
The spacetime divergence
of t alpha beta--
pardon me-- must equal 0.
This is a covariant formulation
of both conservation of energy
and conservation of momentum.
And if you want to
say, well, which one?
Is it energy or is it momentum?
You can't say that in general.
I can only say that after I have
picked a particular reference
frame, because it's only
once I have defined time
and I've defined space
that I've actually
defined energy and momentum.
Prior to choosing a
particular reference frame,
all I have is four-momentum.
One observer's energy is
another observer's superposition
of energy and momentum.
Once I have picked
a particular frame--
so once I have picked a
particular frame, then
if I evaluate d alpha
T alpha either 0 or t,
this is what
conservation of energy
looks like in that frame.
So in that frame, here is
conservation of energy.
I can fit it.
Hang on a second.
No, no, no.
I had it right the first time.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I was just trying
to make sure I got
my indices lined up properly.
So apologies you can't quite
read the bottom one so well.
The top one is
conservation of energy
in that particular frame.
The second one is
conservation of momentum
in that particular frame.
And again, the key thing
which I want to emphasize
is the covariant statement
basically puts both of them
together into a single equation.
I can only sensibly
state conservation
of energy and
conservation of momentum
according to some
particular observer.
Now, I can repeat
the game that I
had done before with
the number vector
and turned these conservation
laws into integral equations
as well.
Let me do it for energy.
So if I take that
integral equation
and integrate over a
three-volume, or if you prefer,
I can take the original
covariant formulation
and integrate that
over a four-volume.
With a little bit
of manipulation
akin to the way I
manipulated the conserv--
the integrals associated
with the number vector
in the previous lecture,
you can write down
a law that looks like this.
And so this-- again,
what I've done here
is I've chosen a particular
set of timeline coordinates.
And the language that we
often use in relativity
is we basically say I'm going
to take a single slice of time.
And I would say that the
rate of change of energy--
so integrate energy
over a volume.
It's the total
energy in that V3.
The rate of change
of that thing is
balanced by the amount
of energy flowing
into or out of through the
boundaries of that volume.
Add an extra index here.
So make this-- make
one of these be a j.
Make this guy be a j.
And you've got a
similar statement
for the conservation
of momentum.
This is a particular trick.
I have a set of typed up
notes that just sort of clean
this up a little bit.
They're basically
exactly this point,
but I'll put them online
after today's lecture.
You're going to want to use this
on one of the p set problems
this week.
So you guys are
going to do a couple
exercises that involve
integrating and actually
finding essentially moments
of the left-hand side
of this thing.
You're going to do
a few exercise where
you take advantage of this
formulation of conservation
of energy and momentum to
derive a few identities involved
in the stress energy
tensor, one of which
is another Easter egg that
we're going to use quite a bit
in a future lecture.
So let me just wrap up our
discussion of the stress energy
tensor by just doing
two more examples.
And then I'm going
to sort of begin
switching gears a little bit.
So far I have only described--
essentially, I've really only
described perfect fluids.
Dust is a perfect
fluid with no pressure.
There are a lot of other kinds
of materials that we want
to work with in the universe.
One of which-- it's unlikely
many of you are going to use
this, but it's actually the
stress energy tensor on which I
have built--
well, I guess Alex is going
to use it a little bit--
I have built a big
chunk of my career.
Suppose you have-- we kind of
talked a little bit about how
the four-velocity
and the four-momentum
are really only good for talking
about like the kinematics
of particles.
Well, actually, particles
aren't a bad thing
to focus on in some
of your studies.
And much of my
research is actually
based on the idea of thinking
about a binary system as one
member being a black
hole, and its companion
being a particle-like
object that
is a particular limit of it,
a particle-like object that
orbits it.
So a really simple
stress energy tensor--
and I'm just
throwing it out here,
because I think it nicely
illustrates the principle.
A point particle with rest
mass, we'll call it m0.
And I'm going to say it's moving
on a particular world line
through spacetime.
So the way we
define a world line
is we just say it's
some four-vector that
describes the place of this
thing from some chosen origin.
And it's generally most
convenient to parameterize it
by the proper time of
whatever object or creature is
moving on that world line.
And so it's a lot like dust,
only there's no volume.
It's sort of like
one particle of dust.
And so the stress energy
tensor we use for this--
let me back up for
just a second here.
When you guys learned about
electricity and magnetism,
one of the first things you
learn about are point charges.
And then a little
bit later you learn
about charge distributions.
And you have charge densities.
And then, usually, at
some point in a class--
it's often like
junior level E&M--
we say, how do you describe
the density of a point charge?
That's where you learn about
the Dirac delta function.
Well, if I have
a point particle,
I'm going to need to
describe this thing's energy
density as essentially
a Dirac delta function.
And so what we do is imagining
that these things-- so this is
the four-velocity of that body.
They might be functions of time
as this guy is moving along
here.
What we do is we introduce
a Dirac delta function
as this thing moves
along through spacetime.
What this does-- you can
check the dimensions.
This gives me exactly
what we need in order
to have something that's
dimensionally correct,
and has all the symmetries
and all the properties
that describe a particle moving
at a particular four-velocity
through spacetime.
Now, you might
want to just-- it's
the thing which I kind of
want to pause on for a second.
You go, what the hell do
you do with this, right?
That's kind of inconvenient.
Well, the trick we use to sort
of clean up that Dirac delta
function, it's
very much like what
you do when you encounter
multidimensional delta
functions in basic physics.
You just build it out of a
bunch of one-dimensional delta
functions.
Likewise, you'll
have a term with a y
component and the z component.
Then you use the rule
that if I integrate
a function of x against a delta
function whose argument is
itself a function
of x, I evaluate
that function at the 0's of g.
So let's say x0 is
where g has a 0.
Normalizing to the
first derivative of g
evaluated at that 0.
When you put all
of that together,
that basically means you can do
this somewhat abstract integral
formally.
I mean, exactly.
You can just do it analytically.
And what you do is you choose
one of the delta functions
to apply it to.
Traditionally, people apply
it to the timeline component.
And what is the derivative
of the world line
z component with
respect to proper time?
It's the 0 component
of the four-velocity.
So you just divide by the 0
component of the four-velocity,
and then you're left with
a three-dimensional delta
function for the spatial
trajectory of this thing
through all space.
So this is an example
of one that just,
again, kind of the intuition
is one of the things
I want to emphasize.
Notice we had-- this
has the symmetries
that we wanted to have.
It's not hard to show that this.
You can think of
this as essentially
being kind like a gamma factor.
This all ends up
giving me just what
we need for this thing to
have the right transformation
properties.
And it does, in fact,
play a role in some--
well, I'll say in some
research that's near
and dear to my heart.
Let me do another example.
Suppose you want to know the
stress energy tensor associated
with a given electric
and magnetic field.
Well, first, let me just quote
for you the exact answer, which
is most compactly written if
we use that Faraday tensor
F, which describes
electromagnetic fields
in a frame-independent fashion,
the way that I introduced it
in the last lecture.
So in units where
basically everything
but pi is set equal to 1, it
ends up turning into this.
So that's a bit of a mouthful.
Let's go in and look at
particular components of it,
though.
So let's say I go into
a particular frame.
I fill in my Faraday
tensor with the form
of electromagnetic field
that I introduced last time.
And I'll just go
through, and I'll
evaluate all the different
components of this thing.
So what you find when you fill
this in is your T00 component,
1 over 8 pi e squared
plus b squared.
That's good.
Hopefully, y'all
remember from basic E&M,
the energy density of an
E-field is e squared over 8 pi
and the right system of units.
Energy density of a b field
is b squared over 8 pi
if you work in God's units.
Let's do the
timespace component.
So again, hack through
that mess there.
This is going to be
something that is a vector.
In fact, it's the
Poynting vector.
Could it be anything else?
If you use the recipe
that I sort of suggested
as the easiest way
to approach this,
this is kind of what
you would have guessed
for something like that.
The bit that's
actually kind of hard
is then trying to get the
spatial stresses of this thing.
And here I don't have
any great intuition
for this one to convey to you.
It's derived in textbooks
like Griffiths and Jackson.
So I'll just quote
for you the result.
So you get one term that looks
like E squared plus b squared
on the diagonals.
Then there's a correction,
which looks like this.
I want to just quickly
call out one example
so you can see what the
significance of this example
is.
So suppose you have something
like a pair of capacitors.
And there's just a uniform
electric field between them.
You want to evaluate
the stress energy
tensor between those
pairs of capacitors.
So my spatial electric
field, let's say it just
points in the Ex direction.
And it's constant.
So when you actually
evaluate this guy,
there's no energy flow.
There's no magnetic field.
So there's no Poynting vector.
You, of course, have E squared
over 8 pi for your energy
density.
Very different from
a perfect fluid.
And this kind of makes sense.
That's sort of
telling you that there
is a stress that
if you have a pair
of plain parallel capacitors,
you tend to attract
the plates to each other.
But there is a
pressure associated
with that electric
field that actually
goes in the other directions.
This is your x direction.
This is y and z.
And as a consequence of this--
so there's some
stuff which we're not
going to do too much
with in this class,
but I may give you
some pointers on this.
Electric and
magnetic fields, they
generate pressures, at
least in certain directions.
They kind of generate like
an anisotropic pressure.
And when we start
coupling this to gravity,
you can get electric
fields and magnetic fields
that contribute non-negligibly
to the gravity of their object.
That is it for the
stress energy tensor.
As I said, we are going to
use this guy over, and over,
and over again.
And the reason for
this does come back
to that little motivation that
I gave probably about 45 minutes
ago where we sort of looked at
the Newtonian field equation,
and then said, picking
out a particular scalar
as the source of
gravity makes no sense
in a relativistic
covariant theory.
It's got to be the whole tensor.
And indeed, this is the
one-- well, not the E&M one,
but the general notion
of a stress energy tensor
is the one that we are
going to use for that.
So we have about
10 minutes left.
And so I would like to start
the process of switching gears.
Before I do that, are
there any questions?
I will clean the board.
So the reason we
are switching gears
is we now have probably the
most important physical tools
that we need in order
to start thinking
about making a relativistic
theory of gravity.
But we need a few more
mathematical tools.
In particular, I'm going to
argue in a couple of lectures
that flat spacetime is
not sufficient for us
to build a theory of gravity.
We're going to need
to-- first of all,
you're going to have to
understand what that means.
And we're not quite
ready to go there.
So for now, it's
just fancy words.
But I'm going to
have to introduce
some kind of a notion of
curvature into things.
What does that even mean really?
We need to have the
tools to do that.
And so as a prelude to
going in that direction--
I will call this my
prelude to curvature--
what we're going
to start doing is
flat spacetime in
curvilinear coordinates.
And the importance
of doing this,
why this is going
to be useful to us
is that it will introduce a--
it'll keep the physics simple.
It's still going to
be special relativity,
but it's now going
to special relativity
using a mathematical structure
in which the basis vectors are
no longer constant.
So that's going to
allow us to begin
making a couple of the
mathematical tools that
are necessary to build
gravity into this theory.
So we'll start by
replacing this with just
simple plain polar coordinates
mapped in the usual way.
So if we want to
go back and forth,
well, at least one
way transformation,
I build x and y from r
and phi in that usual way.
There's an inverse
mapping as well,
which involves trig functions.
So I'm not going
to write it down.
One point which I really
want to emphasize here
is we are going to continue
to use a coordinate basis.
And to remind you
what that means,
so a coordinate basis means that
the differential displacement
vector from an event
a to a nearby event b
is simply related
by differentials
of my coordinate contracted
onto my basis vectors.
But when I'm working
in a curvilinear
coordinate system like
this, that means one of them
has a somewhat different form
from what you are used to.
When you guys talk
about the differential
of a displacement in just
about every physics class
up to now, if you have
a differential angle,
you'd want to throw an r.
So this has the
dimensions of length.
We ain't going to do that.
And so what this means,
since this is an angle,
every component of this has
the dimensions of length.
That means that
my basis vector is
going to be something that
has the dimensions of length
associated with it.
This in turn means that this is
not going to be a normal basis.
That's unfortunately a
somewhat loaded word.
What I mean by that is that
it has not been normalized.
But given that you guys have
spent all of your career
thinking about the dot product
of a unit vector with itself--
of a basis vector with
itself being equal to 1,
the other meaning of normal
might be good for you, too.
The key thing which I
want to emphasize here
is e phi dot e phi
does not equal 1.
One other little bit
of notation which
I would like to introduce--
so we are going to want to
talk about transformations
between different
representations.
We've done this-- so
far, we have generally
focused on moving between
different reference frames.
I want to generalize
this notion.
And I'm going to tweak
my notation a little bit
to indicate the difference.
So I'm going to call
capital L alpha mu
bar what I get when I just look
at the variation of the alpha
coordinate system--
sorry-- the unbarred coordinate
system with the barred one.
So this is just--
there's no deep things here.
I just want you to be familiar
with the notation which
I'm going to use.
I will always reserve lambda
for the Lorentz Transformation.
So in the interest of time, I'll
just write down one of these.
So this sort of means
like, for instance,
suppose that I'm transforming.
Let's let barred indicate
my polar coordinates.
Unbarred be Cartesian.
These things are surprisingly
sticky sometimes.
So if I want to transform
in one direction
between my barred
and my unbarred ones,
this matrix will go through it.
And it looks like this.
So this is the thing which
I will call l alpha mu bar.
In my notes, I also give
the inverse transformation.
And I will actually write--
you know what?
I have minute.
I will write that
one down as well.
If you want to know how to
go in the other direction,
it's just the matrix
that inverts this.
The reason I decided to
take the extra 30 seconds
or so to write
this down is I want
to call out the fact that in
this kind of transformation,
because of the fact that this
is a coordinate basis that
has this somewhat
unusual property,
different elements of the matrix
have different dimensions.
It's a feature, not a bug.
So this is going to show up.
I'm going to do a
couple more calculations
with this a little
bit tomorrow-- sorry--
not tomorrow, on Tuesday.
This is going to show up in
the way the metric looks.
The metric is going to have
a very different character
in this coordinate system.
And we're going to
see the way in which--
it basically boils down
to it's going to pick up
a non-trivial functional form.
It's not going to
just be a constant.
And that fundamentally
reflects the fact
that the basis vectors
are not constant anymore.
We'll end it there.